une table ronde pour briser le tabou de
l'incontinence à l'origine de
l'événement la start-up noé a réuni la
députée aurore bergé des professionnels
des aidants et des personnes confrontées
à ce mal objectif récolter des
témoignages pour en apprendre davantage
et trouver des solutions
je vous parlerai de la situation de
l'entreprise julian qui est en ce sens
d'un polyhandicap on a eu des
témoignages aujourd'hui qui sont
bouleversants d'une maman d'un enfant
polyhandicapé de 10 ans dont on voit les
douleurs au quotidien les difficultés
une fille d'une maman de 93 ans qu'il
accompagne au quotidien et puis toutes
les personnes aides soignantes
auxiliaires de vie infirmière qui
évidemment accompagne et interviennent
donc non seulement ça concerne beaucoup
de personnes mais on parle vraiment de
la dignité humaine
en france 11 millions d'aidants sont
concernés pour leurs proches ils font
face à un manque d'information
d'une part pour nous les aidants mais de
façon générale grand public et pas du
tout de formation du personnel que ce
soit en hôpital
que ce soit au niveau des auxiliaires de
vie à domicile
pourtant si ce mal reste encore tabou
aujourd'hui une incontinence m'a
accompagné peut engendrer de nombreux
problèmes il ya dooly's au mans sociale
il ya des risques de chutes à domicile
il ya des pertes financières
il ya des risques de retour aux urgences
également dans les hôpitaux
donc il faut prendre ce ce sujet très au
sérieux la start-up nos essais donc
spécialisée dans l'accompagnement
personnalisé des personnes incontinentes
à domicile plusieurs solutions ont été
développées
on va leur rendre visite à domicile nous
allons créer un lien social et nous
allons calculer leur calendrier
mictionnels pour définir quels types de
protections pour la jours et pour la
nuit seront adaptées à leur cas
particulier
la start up sortira prochainement une
application mobile pour mieux
accompagner les patients est-ce que vous
pouvez nous raconter